hey
so this is macros for a more productive
rust
uh just a little bit about me before i
get started
my name is jam i use hem pronouns
professionally i do security research
however in my free time i mostly focus
on
modding uh general open source
stuff so
macros here's the simplest macro
it's composed of only a few parts you
have the
declaration which just sets what the
name of the macro is
you have the pattern which essentially
handles
parsing the input to the macro
so you might have different types of
syntax fragments so you might have
expressions you might have names of
types
you might have identifiers
you can basically pass arbitrary rust
into it and you can set
what different things you want to match
against
and so then you have the expansion which
the expansion is what the macro becomes
after you call it so as the name implies
is what it expands into uh so and then
you also have
here's an instance in
here's an example of calling the macro
so in this case just passing in a symbol
3 which is a valid expression
and if we want to see what it looks like
when this expands
we just basically take the expansion and
we template in
the variable that we're passing in so in
this case it's just num
which is uh going to be prefixed by a
dollar sign
and so then it expands to this if you
want to expand things on your own
there's two really great resources for
it there's cargo expand which is a cargo
sub command made by david tolnay
which is which just allows you to see
okay
what happens when my macro expands what
is it expanding to
and you also have the ability to
under the rust playground at the bottom
of the tools section you have the
ability to expand your macros and so
highly recommend going on rust
playground in order to play around with
that
so another feature of macros
is that you can have it match against
something
multiple times so kind of like regex
where you have
star plus and question mark to control
the amount of times you match against
something
it's exactly the same here in rust you
define a capture group and then
you say okay how many times do i want
this to repeat so you use like star if
you want
zero or more you have question mark if
you want it to be
once or no times and then another
the last you know big feature of macro
rules macros
is that you can have multiple different
patterns that you're matching against
and
the different patterns can have
different expansions
and so that allows you to essentially
encode parsing logic in order to figure
out how you actually want to handle your
expansion
so in this case it's just a simple macro
which expands
differently based off of whether or not
you pass a two or three into it
simple enough so when we put those all
together
we can do a lot cooler things with macro
rules macros
so for example we have this trade called
as
bytes it's a simple trade all it does
is takes whatever structure that
implements
as bytes and then it converts it
into a vector of bytes so for example if
we want to implement it for u16
we might use the associated functions
for converting u16s into bytes
simple enough but the thing is is that
if you have to type this in for every
different integer type
it's going to be a lot of repetitive
code and it's not going to be easy
to manage it after you've written it
and it's going to be harder to not
necessarily harder to read but it's just
going to be a lot to read
and anytime you have to go in and make a
change you have to change all of them
but we can remove that if we
use repetition from before in order to
implement the trait for all of the
integer types at once
and so the way we can do that is first
we just wrap our
example implementation in a
macro we set it to repeat
we then make it so that we have our
pattern
be matching against repeated comma
separated type names
and then we replace every instance of
u16
with our type name and so that allows it
to
it says okay generate this code in
multiple repetitions of it
for whatever given types we pass in and
so
then if we call it with all of the types
it'll generate
implementations for all of those types
and then we only have
one implementation that we have to
maintain and it's the templated one
and so some intermediate techniques for
macro rules macros is you can use
internal rules
which basically in this example we have
two macros we have
macro one we have macro two and macro 1
calls onto macro 2 and that might be
necessary because
like i said earlier the only way to
really encode parsing logic
is if you have multiple patterns or
rules that you are matching against in
order to encode that logic
and so if we have to have multiple steps
of parsing logic then we end up having
to have
essentially multiple macros to handle
each layer of logic
and so in this case uh this actually
causes a problem because if we
import uh macro 1 into scope but not
macro 2
then macro 1 tries to use macro 2 after
it expands
but it's not in scope so how do we fix
this
so basically what we're going to do is
we're going to collapse the two
into a single macro and so the way we do
that
is with internal rules and internal
rules are basically
you have a pattern that starts with at
which
that's just by convention but it's
highly recommended because
at isn't really used very often in rust
syntax
so it's not likely to cause any
collisions with
the things you're actually trying to
match against and so in this case
since our previous macro is called macro
tool 2
we instead have a rule that matches
against
at macro2 and so basically what that
allows us to do
is we can have macro one recursively
call itself
but then passing at macro2 at the start
of the
inputs to macro one in order to call the
internal rule
and so another important technique is
called
a tt mantra and so tt stands for token
tree
and basically what's happening here is
that if you
everything in rust is going to be split
up into tokens
uh you know basically in a tree format
because if you have like
brackets everything inside of the
brackets is going to be a child
of that the bracket tokens in your token
tree
and so if you match against repeated
token trees then you match against
everything that gets passed into the
macro and so if you match against
something and then the rest of the token
trees
then you can essentially say okay i'm
only matching against the first token
and then i can pass the rest of those
token trees
back into the macro and so i can handle
parsing
one set of tokens at a time so
in this example we have matching against
either
up or down and each time it's followed
by the rest of the token trees
and so if we actually look at what that
what happens when we try to handle that
is we have up up down down and then
it matches against that first up for the
first branch of it
and then it take captures the up down
down as the rest of the token trees
and then it passes that back in to the
macro
so then it's just another call of up
down down and then those recursive calls
allow us to handle it one at a time
going
down down and then down and then we hit
our base case which is just
when nothing gets passed in we then just
do nothing and so after that it expands
into nothing and then we
have all of our code and we've been able
to handle it one step
one set of tokens at a time so we can
have
multiple repeating tokens but each one
has parsing logic for handling okay
i match against up where i match against
down and so
one really useful crate for when you're
writing macro rules macros is called
paste
and so one of the limitations of macro
rules macros is that you can't create
new identifiers
but what paste allows you to do to
circumvent that is
it allows you to concatenate different
identifiers in order to create a new
identifier so in this example
it has the four identifiers q r s and t
and it concatenates all of those to form
qrst
and so
absolutely great create
if you wanted to find this crate or
other crates like it
uh david tolnay the person who actually
made paste
actually has a site that allows you
to look at a lot of useful stuff related
to macros
it's actually his github
so proc macros the
other type of macro different from macro
rules so
proc macros the general idea is that
you're writing
another rust program which then
takes in a series of tokens and then
it returns a series of tokens
and so for example we have function like
macros which are basically
the same thing as macro rules macros
except they're a little bit more
powerful because they're proc macros
and you can have arbitrary rust logic
for determining how you modify your
stream of tokens
so in this example it's a json macro
from rocket and it allows you to
essentially
just trade up right json within your
code
and even use rust expressions as values
or keys within your json
and that's great for like if you're
writing a web server and
you want a quick ergonomic way to build
a json response
a wonderful way to do it and so then we
also have attribute macros
so attributes are just those little
things that go before functions or
static variables or anything like that
and so
what this allows us to do is essentially
associate data or some action or
something with the
function or static or whatever
itself and so in this example from
rocket it's the get attribute macro and
so what that allows you to do
is you can mark a function as a http git
handler
and so in the example we have the path
slash hello slash name slash age and
basically what it does is it
takes whatever url path you're going to
so like it might be slash hello slash
jam
slash whatever and then it handles the
name and age and actually passes it into
those functions
and so that allows you to remove a lot
of boilerplate that would otherwise be
required
for either handling the different routes
or actually handling pulling the
information out of the routes and it
makes it a little bit more robust as you
don't actually have to
have the error-prone nature of trying to
pull that information out yourself
and so lastly we have derived macros
and essentially if you're familiar with
rust you're probably familiar with the
concept of
deriving things like clone or debug
or copy and so what derive macros allow
you to do is allows you to
have your own derived handler for
implementing a trade automatically
and so here's an example from saturday
in which you can and what saturday
allows you to do is allows you to derive
serialize and deserialize for
arbitrary structs or enums and
then you can actually serialize it or
deserialize it
to and from whatever format supports
certain so for example satay json is a
great for converting to and from
json strings and it's absolutely great
you should definitely check it out and
so proc macros uh if you want to create
one yourself all you have to do is
create a new library throw proc macro
equals true in your tomml
and then you just have to make a
function which takes in a token stream
and outputs a different stream
so here's an example of how we can make
a proc macro
and so what this does is this is a
attribute macro
which you put it at the top of a
function
and what it'll do is it'll insert a
print statement at the beginning of the
function
so that it prints out okay i'm entering
this function
which allows you to trace things so
basically the way this macro works
is first up we have a line that uses syn
parse macro input and so what syn is
syn is it allows you to parse
arbitrary rust source from tokens
so like in this situation it's parsing
the input to our proc
macro as a function and it also handles
the error handling for you so it'll give
you a pretty error
if they try if someone tries to pass in
something other than a function
and so then we take the name of the
function and convert it to a string
and so here's a sin
parse quote and so what that allows you
to do is
quote is a crate which allows you
to essentially pseudo
quote your code and convert it to tokens
so in this situation
we have this macro parse quote and
essentially we can just write whatever
code we want in there kind of like when
we're doing macro rules macros and we
can template
different tokens into it so in this case
i take the function name and i template
it into my code
and then in this case since it's parse
quote instead of just quote
it then parses it into a statement in
this situation
and then we insert that statement at the
beginning of our function block
and then we use quote to convert the
function
back into tokens and return it and
that's all it takes
so let's see some things that show how
powerful
proc macros are so here's an example
called
tree flexion and if you're at all
familiar with
c sharp or java or other object oriented
languages
that have the feature of reflection
essentially what it allows you to do
is it allows you to at runtime take a
look
at what are the actual names
of fields within like a structure or
class or whatever
and what's the layout of them and that
essentially allows you to
just kind of have have programming
related to the layout of your struct
and so in game dev you might use that to
allow
your developer console to
modify arbitrary structures at runtime
and that's a very useful tool and so
what derive macros
in this situation allow you to do is you
can actually kind of replicate
reflection but instead of handling it
all at run time
and incurring those costs you can
instead
have it at compile time because you can
derive it for each of your structures
that you're using
and first off you're not paying for it
for any of the structures that you don't
want accessible
but also you can generate efficient
code for each different type and that
allows you
to essentially have it
so you have compile time reflection
where you're generating unique functions
for each type that handle it as
efficiently as possible for that
specific type
and so here's another example this is a
macro i wrote called bin read
i definitely recommend you check it out
if you are doing any
binary parsing but essentially the idea
of it
is instead of writing a bunch of code
for handling your parsing logic
instead use your struct declaration
and use the ordering of your field and
some
metadata in attributes in order to
actually
encode the parsing logic so that you
don't actually have to
write your parsing code you have your
parsing code generated for you
and so that allows you to have kind of
declarative programming
for your parsing and i think that was a
pretty successful experiment but
one cool thing you can kind of learn
from this is basically when you're
implementing a derived macro what you
want to do is you want to offload
as much of the lot the actual like
code out of the proc macro itself and
into for example like a trade
so in this case i have like been read
the trait
in question implemented for all of the
like integer types and all the other
primitives
and then some more helper types and then
my derived macro all it does is it
generates some code
that a uses the attributes involved with
it in order
to generate some code but also be
to handle just kind of recursively
calling the trait on the types used in
the struct and that's
basically how all derived macros are
going to work
and so
[Music]
and so here's one of the really coolest
examples of how you can use function
like macros
and for a function like proc macros
since you can just
write arbitrary tokens in there because
it's
imbe it's inside of a separator and
therefore
doesn't actually have to be valid rust
like an attribute macro if you attach it
to a function
it still has to be a valid function but
within it
you can kind of it has to like parse
properly
but with function like macros since all
of your tokens are like
in parentheses you can essentially have
arbitrary tokens and you can
encode your own syntax so like maybe
something that's
domain specific like on the top left i'm
encoding
some information about okay this is
just a arbitrary language that allows
you to encode
moveset information for a game so like
okay
wait 16 frames and then create
a hitbox and then do this and that
but an even cooler example of using that
is this crate called inline python
and so you might think inline python
that doesn't make any sense rust has
like it it doesn't care about white
space it's
completely ignores it it just parses the
tokens between the white space so how
can you encode
python like python is dependent on the
white space you have to have your
tabbing correct and everything
but the thing is is what inline python
does
is it looks at your tokens so for
example
in the bottom right we have like the
four and then we have the print on the
next line and we can look at the line
numbers
of those tokens and we can look at the
column numbers of this tokens and we can
figure out okay there is a tab in here
and we can recreate
the white space from the positions of
the tokens
and this allows you to essentially write
arbitrary inline languages for
your specific domain so if you want to
write python
that pulls rust variables you can use
inline python or you can
write your own and that's insanely
powerful
and so here's an example of an attribute
macro
also one i wrote it's called skyline
hook
and essentially what it does is it
allows you to replace
a function in another binary with your
rust function so in this case you just
provide it like a program counter
and then you provide your function and
then it allows you to replace that by
doing a bunch of
nonsense in the background to actually
handle like the code patching and
everything like that
um and it even allows you to call the
original function
in case you actually just want to like
modify some of the input variables and
then
defer to the original uh and one great
example
of how someone used that is a
somebody made a pokemon randomizer um
and so it really just takes one like 50
line function
or it just randomizes some values in
some function it's overriding
and that's all it takes and the
attribute macro actually handles all of
the
inserting your code patching and
everything like that
but can we take macros even further
so in an earlier talk esteban started
talking a lot
about rus plus plus and it got me
thinking you know like
rust great language i love it it's my
favorite language
but like it still needs a lot of
features
like if you think about it like it can't
interrupt with c plus at all like what's
up with that and like
also i don't have the ability to do
inheritance
like is russ not even an object-oriented
programming language
like i don't understand so like the
conclusion i came to is
rust must be a bad language like
you know a good language like sepals
plus
has these features uh kidding obviously
um but uh
still this got me thinking about like oh
you know
what if we actually introduce
inheritance and c
plus plus interoperability with a macro
uh and so i made this crate called cpp
inherit and what it allows you to do
is it allows you to inherit rust types
from
c plus plus types and even like override
virtual functions and in the background
it
you know calls out to gcc and it says
compile this header file
and give me the dwarf information for it
and
show me what the vtable layout is so
that i can recreate it within rust
and it generates a bunch of code in the
background for handling that all for you
so that you can inherit from c plus plus
classes using rust drugs
um and so uh that's all i got
thank you for watching it was a great
time